[音楽]
どうもみなさんはじめまして食卓料理家の森本桃屋と申します
私はよくあの料理を出した出すとえっとみんなに変態料理だって言われるんですけど
変態って言ってもいろいろな意味があると思うんですね
でも私の中での変態っていうのは物事の見方を織女として物事の見方を変えるという
コンセプトで料理をしています
突然ですけどえっと皆さん今日のお昼は何を食べましたか
その前の位は何を食べましたか
さらにその前の日は何を食べたか覚えてますか
でその3日間の食事が自分を作ってるって思うとピンと来たりしますかね
普段皆さんがえっと食事を選ぶ時ってどういった基準で選んでますかね
同市こうだったりとか状況だったりとかそういったもので選んでることが多いかと思い
ます
でも食べ物が自分を作ってるってなるとちょっと見方を変えるだけで面白いことが
わかったりもします
今日はちょっとだけ食べ物の見方を変えて食事というものを考えてもらえればなぁと
思います
と例えばですけど a 棟
がむしゃらに号毎日遅くまで夜遅くまで働いてえっと食事はコンビニへ巣立ったもう
時間がなくてコンビニだったり
カップラーメンだったり外食だったりっていう人も多いかと思いますってあのもう久々
に早くは誰か飲みに行こうなんてっていっぱい以降アルコールを一杯飲んではい
もう具好きでしたからもうラーメンなんかでもの大ないか締めにラーメン食べて帰ろう
なんて優秀方も結構いらっしゃいますよね私もよく
前は飲んだりしたらラーメン絶対食べたくなるんですけ
でラーメン屋行ったら貼り方米お願いしますって言っちゃったりしてでもその時に実は
カラダの中で
どういうことが起こっているかなっていうのをちょっと今日は代弁して言ってみようか
なと思います
いやーマジで人手足りないのに一応仕事いっぱい来るんだけど
なんかアルコールとか今日めっちゃきてもう分解追いつかないのにまだ何か仕事とか来
くるし
いやいや下やバリカタ大目ってほんと徹夜でってことだや店名
もうほんとなんか休みないしどんだけ働かせんだよ
みたいなそんな感じかなって思います
消化って意外と重労働だったりするんですよね
であのやっぱり消化が終わってないのにまたあの消火をしなきゃいけない
普段必要なあの栄養素が偏ってたりするとその時に必要な栄養素がなかったです
いうと消化がまた遅れちゃったりとか負担になっちゃったりしていろんなものが滞っ
たりします
あとを労働環境が整ってないのに何か仕事がめっちゃくるみたいな
もう体からしてみればブラック企業なわけですよね
まあそんなこと言ったらね何を食べればいいんだよみたいな話になってきますので
まぁでもなんか自分を考案の食べ物が自分を作ってるってなるとやっぱり自分を作るの
はあの子で自分がデザインできるんじゃないかなと思うんですよね
なので洋服のコーディネートをするように食
うちもコーディネートするって思うとちょっと楽しくなるんじゃないかなと思います
じゃあ続いてはですねちょっと普段食べているものがどんなものなのかっていうのを
深く考えるみたいな視点をあの
提案しようかなと思っています
突然ですがちょっと今日のメニューでございます
次のメニューどちらかからお選びいただけますでしょうか
a
青虫の載った皿だ
b 見た目めっちゃ綺麗なサラダ
じゃあちょっと表現買えますね
無農薬農園直送のレタスのサラダ枝豆で作った青虫の線
b オフィス直送 led レタスのサラダ
変色しない漂白剤ドレッシング添え
じゃあ次いきますもうちょっとさらに表現を変えてみます
はいっ
じゃあどちらからかお選びください栄養素や微生物
たっぷりサラダ b 栄養素や微生物をたっぷり排除したサラダ
じゃあこの3つはですねえとどれも同じサラダです
で a には青虫が乗っていますあをむしっても黒くて汚い見るのもやだなんてみんな
思いますよねってもう青虫が乗ってたサラダなんてもう汚い汚いみたいな
でもあおむしは極端に言うと見方を変えれば
良質なたんぱく質だったりしますなので
枝豆と大外してもいけるんじゃないかなって思ったんですね
ねあのそれでもやっぱりとんどもめんどくさいし
なんか
ほんと見た目めっちゃキレイのサラダのほうがいいじゃんなんて言うとやっぱり農薬を
撒いて無償排除したり
えっと漂白剤とかにつけてあの雑菌したりしますねさっきんですね
入っでそうするとやっぱりメタ見た目は綺麗ですけどあの人間に必要な栄養素
もう無くなっちゃうこともあるんです
皆さんどちらを選びますか
まあとは言ってもですね私もあの
17-20代とか10代から30代まではもうめっちゃジャンクフードばかり食べて
ます
あの
パテシエを10年やっていてお菓子作りを貸すもうすごい好きで
もうやり外需もうやりがい重視でめちゃめちゃ朝から晩まで働いてましたなぁさから缶
コーヒー飲んだりもうポテトチップス食べたりケーキ食べたりとかそういう生活をして
たんですね
9年目に転職をします
して同じおかしい業界なんですけど店が変わったことによって環境が合わなくなって
あの
なんて言うんですかねいじめに遭っちゃったりとかしてそれでなんかあの心と身体の
バランス食生活とかも変わったので心とば体のバランスが崩れていきました
でえっとそれと同時にですね2つの難病を発症してそれであのわけもわからずどうして
もいいかも分からないのでとりあえず病院行って脳神経麻痺させる薬とかステロイドと
かすごい飲んだりとかで途中うつ病も発症してですね
入眠剤とか安定剤ステロイドとか
もうすごい1日に何種類もの薬を飲んでも意識がもうろうとするみたいな
でなんか怒鳴られたりするとまぁみたいな感じで本当にもう何通して何を食べてもいい
のかもあらずに食べては吐いてみたいなことを繰り返していました
本当に廃人状態みたいな感じになって逃げるようにあの前職を辞めました
ですねえっと
あのう
運良くオーガニックレストランでウエイトシェフをさせていただくことになりました
でそこでですねえっといろんなう show it をさばいたりとかしていろんな何
か良い後 or 叩く
いただくありがたみとかあとは野菜のおいしさとかを知り食の大事さを知ることにでき
ました
その後さんあのそれを機に薬とかやめて35日の断食とかをしていろいろで
dogs とかをし始めましたそうするとだんだん感覚が戻ってきてなんかあの
いろいろ自分をカスタムする面白さを知ってきたんですね例えばストレスですごいも
ジャンクフードとかあのなんていうんですかね
ポテトチップスとかすごい私2袋ぐらいドカ食いしちゃうんですけど
そんなたびに入ったりとかしてたんですけどもうすそれもひと袋とかでもやっぱし
ちゃうんですけどそのために薬草茶とか発酵食品とかそう
みんなほど飲んで調節したりみたいなことをするようになりました
でそうやって毎日の食卓がすごい自分にはだいたいやっぱり自分を作ってるんだなと
いうことを知って自分の料理で毎日の食卓づくりのお手伝いができないかなって思う
ようになりました
で現在はですねみんなのお母さんという肩書であの
子育てとかあと産前産後のお母さんと彼が自分のやっぱり
食べる美味しく食事を食べる時間や子供と遊ぶ時間をちゃんと守ってほしい
そのために何かお手伝いは出来ないかという事でごたご家庭に合わせた
越冬レシピとかでえっと作り容器とかをしています
でこちらはですねえっと特別な日の食卓づくりとしてえっと
これはお食い初めですね子供の初めてのお食い初めとかをあのお母さんとお父さんと
一緒に作ったりということもやってます
でこの食卓づくりってことで8一番最初に出しをいろんなダッシュをテイスティングし
てもらってご自分の家の味を決めるみたいな感じのこともやったりしました
でまぁ変態ほりかって言われるのはこういった
フィベントのケータリングとかが多いんですけどこれはイベントのケータリングで常識
を疑う
ケータリングを作ってほしいという依頼をいただきましてえっと普段使わない未利用魚
へと坂あの
普段使わない魚ですね未利用魚とかをあのおいしい
良い状態を見出してあの打っていらっしゃる魚コンシェルジュの方がいるのでその方
からあの仕入れた欲しい a やシリア経過などを料理したりあとは野草とかをサラダ
にしました
でこのやそうあのこのイベントに参加したオフィスワーカーが後日野草にすごい興味
思ってそれであのに入って野草取り入って
村たりしてたのには驚きました
最後になりましたがえっと皆さん好き嫌いとかありますかね
で実は好き嫌いとかって体が自分に必要なものと必要じゃないものを表しているサイン
だったりします普段好きだけどきょうはちょっと食べたくないなぁと思うことも
いつもは必要だけど今日はいらないよ
って言ってる3位んだったりもします
が何を食べたらいいとか何を食べたら良くないとか言いたいわけじゃないんですね
ただやっぱの思考や情報で食べるのではなく
あの五感をフルに使って本当に自分がこれを食べたいこれを食べたくないっていうのを
体にこう聞いたりとか
なんか感覚で選んだりとかしてもらえたら面白いんじゃないかなって思います
食卓はえっと未来を
自分の民未来の自分を創る1つのピースだと思って
あの
欲しいなって思います
じゃ
と最後に皆さんじゃあ今日は何を食べますか
そしてどんな自分を作りますか
ありがとうございます